[Music]
hypocrite news oh you sneaky snake I
love being a hypocrite be submitted by
Hollywood is crazy
nitro yeah one of the leading women in
the me to movement reportedly assaulted
the teenage boy good for her sexually
assaulted [ __ ] attacked at work so you
guys know oh yeah
well that's how her name is spell but
it's pronounced no it's Asia okay Asia
because she's trying to make it all
fancy its Asia is your black lady with
the name Asia she's Italian she's oh no
nevermind anthony bourdain before he
died Oh apologies I thought I was old
black lady those agents that never seen
her before I think it's been an actress
yes she's an Italian actress oh that's
why my dinner a beautiful my Thurman's
sister or something I don't know right
those cheekbones
she got a bug on her forehead look at
little kid that the moms are barest
about yes your boobs are weird [ __ ]
Joe let me take away I'm so sorry about
him oh my god family what's the divorce
he did do that when he was a kid he said
that yeah it might now my nephews that
oh I think its genetic all right so
she's also a director by the way so she
was one of the first people to accuse
Harvey Weinstein and I'm gonna show you
guys a video clip but when she did it
she did it that can Film Festival oh no
there's a speech the infamous speech
yeah here we go I know
seven I was raped by Harvey Weinstein
why does she look like that one years
old this festival was his hunting ground
you know this so you showed me a picture
where she used to be hot he's still
pretty attractive she's really what are
your standards like so this is her right
but in the speech she looks like a
grandma I mean yeah she aged a little
bit more you tricked me that's not the
point that is at the point Joe it's not
if this girl turns you on or not
it's about if it's a bug or not know
what he's doing right now he's trying to
figure out if he wouldn't have minded if
she touched it that's what he started
figure out right yeah because the first
ones okay but the second one no yes I
would have been okay both of them
touched me I feel like it's for boys
it's a because we're a teenage boy
you're fantasize about everyone yeah why
older women to touch you unless you're
gay you want a man to touch you exactly
yeah we've yet to have a guy come into
this room to say but it didn't say
sexually assaulted said assaults or so
if she beat the [ __ ] out of them boy
doesn't want that sexual yeah who it is
the boy wants that all right so anything
I don't want to get beat up by a girl
sometimes sometimes it'll girls hard
enough I wonder step on my face that's
an entrance no absolutely not
all right let me tell you the story here
so this involves this actor named Jimmy
Bennett oh I've seen me nothing I look
like a monkey that shave this for office
[Laughter]
because the orange peel and stick it in
your mouth yeah look like a monkey what
is called a poo that Homer Simpson
faceball
Homer Simpson has a monkey lower half
tear he does all right yes Jimmy Bennett
he starred in a movie with Asya honey
when he was seven when he was seven
years old he played he looks like uma
Thurman for right oh my god that's when
you got sexual
oh all right that's kind of young yeah
that's kind of odd I'm like 12 it's like
yeah yeah 12 dream come true 7 or like
what the hell's going on yeah cuz that's
when you were like I don't want girls
the hell yeah I want all boyfriends to
hang out with yeah all right so back in
2013
Jimmy was 17 it was just two months
after his 17th birthday Zoey adjusters
17 she was 37 huh they met in Marina del
Rey
there's Instagram photos the one she was
waiting for him
she's like waiting for my long-lost son
my love Jimmy Bennett is that her this
was that day May 9th 2013 when they had
sex and then later on the day she raped
him later on it's this photo here and it
says happiest day of my life reunion
with Jimmy Bennett is that before or
after sighs and then after here's
another when she looks young all of a
sudden there why does her face keep
[ __ ] change that's what I'm saying my
my son my love until I will whoa you
think my son yeah this is important
homepage [ __ ] yeah incestual is that
called word for something so what
happened here he can't drive because he
has he's 14 Oh 17 okay so a family
member drove him to meet with her cuz
they were gonna discuss an upcoming
movie and Asya asked the family member
to leave them alone so they could work
on scenes especially the the hot and
steamy scenes after the family member
left she gave him alcohol and she showed
him a series of notes that she written
to him it's all part of the scene then
she kissed him oh then she pushed them
back on the bed removed his pants and
gave him head and then she claimed on
top of him and then they had sex
what's the party supposed to complain
about so far awesome if they wrote a
romantic book for man the poor man right
that's what I'm saying anything past 12
it's like 12 is when you're like the guy
perspect I think Homer guys yeah the guy
perspective from a guy if when you're 12
like I hope older lady takes advantage
of me and the older you get your it that
gets intensified and when you read down
so you tell me right now you want an
older lady to do that to you right now
at the 37 is not older lady would I just
say that yeah 37 is not old lady -
there's some hot older ladies yeah it's
the fact that he's always beuter as his
mom even better I think the main point
that people harp on freudian sure yeah
that is not see the mort's not trying to
is that he was under the influence of
alcohol no but if you read it though if
it's a few dis let me know if when you
listen to the way you're explaining it
it's like he was mad and he was sat down
thank you here the family was excused
out of the room and then close the
soundproof doors itself and then served
alcohol and he pushed him onto the satin
shoes falling down she pulls down his
pants and puts the dick in his in her
mouth yeah he's like this is her [ __ ]
mouth goes lands on the bed at the same
no the beginning of wedding crashers
we're just all the naked chicks falling
yeah that's how I imagine is do like go
on like slow motion boom and all the
silk sheets like yeah so did he get so
like drunk that he didn't know what's
going on he woke up and you're like oh
no so then after sex they had lunch and
then she even fed him lunch too this is
[ __ ] great that's the ultimate test I
don't understand how the salts okay
where do we go wrong okay let me tell
you yeah tell me where it went wrong
because I'm still like wait it sounds
great so far yeah because how you're
describing it you see like his red film
over this movie ultimate test is this so
if he was disgusted right his lunch he'd
probably have like one bite of like the
steak or whatever
finish the whole food that means he had
a great I'm assuming he was fine with
the whole thing but not until he was on
his way home back to OC that's when he
started realizing like wait I feel gross
like this doesn't feel right like awful
poisoning food poisoning he feels like I
used used pieces you were just like the
delayed like realization of what just
happened oh it's cuz he came and then
after he came [ __ ] sense to me to his
head yeah that makes sense
but wait a minute whoa that's true
because this guy he's an actor he
probably gets a lot of girls so then his
standards are really really high so when
he sees her he might be thinking oh I
can't believe I just [ __ ] that thing
no well the lawyer was saying like he
viewed her as a mother figure and like
he felt like she took advantage of him
by the way things panned out and he just
he had emotional distress and they also
mentioned that in the five years before
2013 he made more than 2.7 million but
then after his income dropped to an
average of 60,000 a year which he
attributes to the trauma that that's
work came from and then so she agreed to
pay him so that's why this just like
[ __ ] hit the fan cuz she's the one
that's like the loudest voice for the me
to movement but she paid off her
accusers so she agreed to pay him three
hundred and eighty thousand dollars as a
17 year old boy you see this hot lady
who literally pushed you onto a bed in
[ __ ] it's not a hot lady it's a lady
that you think is your mobile not
actually related shut up but since he
was no no no here's the problem oh he
news to Sarah Sarah
no no but here's the problem though like
he went through the act even had lunch
with her and then he realized it
afterwards it's not her fault that he
had a deep delayed reaction nobody's
months from being 18 like I see cannot
become a ten month ten months is he
gonna mature is this IQ gonna jump up
fifty points like seventeen is eighteen
sixteen that's the 35 just as dumb at 17
as I was at 24 yeah 25 is like less dumb
a little bit smarter and year by year I
got less dumb I'm still waiting for that
point right now the way it's panned out
and she did if she did take advantage of
him I think that is completely messed up
but speaking from a guy's perspective 17
18 is the exact same thing yeah you have
this arbitrary number that the law put
out but is the exact
same thing I also think it depends on
person-to-person like you can't like
quantify like yeah one guy at 17 could
be the same as one guy like thirty and
one guy like 12/14 I was like I gotta I
gotta have sex with another virgin or
else it's not true love 15 I was like
[ __ ] that Jack me--off suck me up I'll
give a book yeah 13 there's other people
that are starting Facebook already you
know so it's like the numbers to me
doesn't matter but 17 is pretty much 18
because if my mom tried to have sex with
me
I'd like get the [ __ ] off me like if she
gave me alcohol and she exactly you know
that's the problem real mom so that's
the problem is that it's not incestual
right it's just like how you perceive
someone the problem is he went through
it all and then came in after trying to
do like legal [ __ ] that's not fair
though because you're comparing his
mindset to yours that like how old her
about this what if I convinced you to
smoke crack with me what am I
we're both minors okay but I convinced
you to smoke crack with me you had a
blast three days later you regret the
decision and then you come after me and
blame me for pressuring you to do it
but at the same time you went through
with it yeah I made the choice yeah
gonna stop in the middle he was fully
aware he's 17 he's fully aware of what
he's doing he's getting his dick sucked
he could have said no throughout the
whole entire process even when he had
lunch with them you know it's like that
disease around this whole thing because
if he was a girl and she was a dude like
no I guarantee you would not be having a
fight - me and Kylie Jenner and Tyga
yeah what is that what is that what is
that yeah we're dating when he was she
was like 16 right and he's like 7 years
old but damning evidence the fact that
he had a sandwich after that's what I'm
if you didn't eat the [ __ ] Sam yeah a
little prick I would be on your side but
you ate a delicious sandwich with some
lace chips I questioned the motive [ __ ]
it
Oh what [ __ ] established you I see both
sides I can use so hard to well the
thing is realizing elves will get more
sympathy but the problem is whether it's
a male or female if someone does it this
way like replace it with a girl I would
still say that it's wrong for the girl
to come back and and deal with this
legally here's a technicality that
probably none of us know maybe even the
article writer doesn't know but a lot of
actors there are emancipated adults so a
lot of them they want to be able to sign
all their own papers or contract laws so
who knows if he's actually he might be a
legal minor but he actually might be a
conservative at all under the the laws
eyes he might have emancipate him
someone's like sixteen or something so
if that's the case then he willingly did
all of this as an adult now and I
severely questioned the motive behind
all of this because the money part - yep
also I do want to see the sandwich and
see how many bites exactly only took one
bite that means he was dissatisfied with
this meal yeah I was disgusted with
himself if you wait the whole thing and
there was just that one little crumb of
chip left and I want to see that condom
load did he bust low oh but if there's a
couple drops then depending on now how
you're enjoying it you can dictate the
amount that comes out scientifically is
only a little come came out that means
he jacked off or had sex earlier so his
libido isn't this hot yeah do it
yeah I sigh I mean he was really fun so
many different uh angles yeah guys we
should be detective yeah I want to
squeeze it out like this let's see the
amount of cops are going to question is
he the two people where like get out it
just then I look at the trash let me
smell the sheets what is this
f-word saying it - there's all these
numbers popping up behind us in the
banana he enjoyed it clearly they had
sex about three hours oh yes because
there's three of you that needs to do
one job because our pathetic hey we're a
team effort okay
like coming out csy thoughts I think I
felt something
let me smell your balls look it's clean
enough all right we're done
[Music]